welcome back to CBS this morning for the
first time in the historic public
impeachment hearings we'll hear from
witnesses who were on the July 25th call
between President Trump and the
president of Ukraine in this first
session State Department employee
Jennifer Williams and Lieutenant Colonel
Alexander bin Minh will testify they
have both expressed reservations over
that phone call in the later session Tim
Morrison formerly on the National
Security Council will answer questions
along with the former special envoy to
Ukraine kurt volker this is the first of
three days of impeachment hearings this
week with five more witnesses planned
chief Washington correspondent major
Garrett joins us from Washington major
good morning so some was about a
possible witness the President of the
United States he said he's interested in
writing written testimony potentially is
that gonna happen no it's not the
probability of that is next to zero
absolute zero that is what you would
classify as an improvisational outburst
something we've seen before from the
president not compatible with a well
thought out or well executed impeachment
strategy his lawyers would say that
privately they just can't say it
publicly so propositional outburst an
apt description okay so to some more
considered testimony overnight we got
the transcript from the embassy staff
for David Holmes career diplomat who was
there with Gordon Sandlin in that
Ukraine cafe where apparently the
president called Sandlin what's the
significance of Holmes's testimony that
he heard it that he will testify under
oath that the president talked not only
about this issue of investigations but
when Gordon Sandlin was asked after the
phone call what's the president
interested is he care about Ukraine this
witness will say no he just cares about
bigger things things that are more
important to him in this case
investigation so it's a fact witness who
heard something and will provide
testimony that backs up some of the
earlier testimony specifically from
William Taylor on this call and its
potential relevance to the president's
state of mind and intent so up first
today major we're hearing about Jennifer
Williams and the lieutenant colonel Ben
Minh who the president is called
nevertrump errs first is there any
evidence that there never Trump hers
number one and number two what do you
expect to hear from there
testimony today no evidence that I'm
aware of but evidence is always in these
matters in the eye of the beholder and
the president sort of wants to
preemptively suggest there's something
wrong about their testimony because they
might have some other loyalties that's
been problematic for the president
because the witnesses so far seem to
have and represent emphatically one
priority the country its national
interest and their working relationship
within the bureaucracy designed to
advance those national interests so
trying to undercut them by saying there
is something suspicious about their
origins and not dealing with the facts
has been a long-running
White House and Republican tactic but it
has not succeeded because more often
than not these witnesses say I'm not
here for politics I'm here for country
for service my resume backs that up and
here's my testimony major the
president's tweet against former Ukraine
ambassador Maria de yovanovich last week
during her testimony in fact kind of
complicated the Republicans defense and
and some Republicans spoke to the
president after that you think it's
likely to change things at all yes the
president called several members from
the oval office I'm told on Friday and
wanted a readout and he got some bad
news the readout was mr. president that
tweet didn't help you complicated
matters for us please don't tweet about
this do what you did on Wednesday say
you're not focused on this and let us
handle the blocking and tackling in the
committee room that's what the
Republican message the president was he
took it on board I'm told but also said
I got to be me I am Who I am I'm always
gonna rely on my instincts the whilst
Republicans said yes sir but your
instincts on Friday vastly
overcomplicated something that shouldn't
have been a complicated by your tweet
don't do that yeah Twitter notifications
on for today's testimony major thank you
very much and a reminder of CBS News
we'll bring you this morning's public
hearing in a special report nor
O'Donnell will anchor it from Washington
and we expect the testimony to begin at
9:00 Eastern